we've heard a few reports on when the  new zelda game is coming and now you can  add another to the pile I'm Tony and  this is your unreleased game spot news  update blogger Emily Rogers originally  reported that breadth of the wild would  miss the Nintendo switches launch window  but a new report from Eurogamer says  otherwise the website says it will  indeed release in march alongside the  new console note that this is  specifically for the north american and  japanese releases with the european date  not yet locked in several of Eurogamer's  earlier reports have been confirmed but  as always you should still take this  with a grain of salt in any case we  shouldn't have to wait much longer for  official confirmation the nintendo  switch presentation is set for Thursday  January 12th at 8pm Pacific expect to  hear all about the specs price and  launch lineup we'll have it all up on  gamespot but for all the latest from  Nintendo you're already in the right  place